in most games the best characters seem
awesome to play rewarding to practice
and fair to play against win or lose but
then there are those characters that
throw good game design balance in the
garbage characters that make you want to
break your keyboard in half when you die
to their cheesy [ __ ] today we're
ranking the characters that ruin scenes
destroyed games and chess planes suck to
play against but before we jump in i
have to remind you as always to like
button the subscribe button and to ring
that notification bell and i will love
you forever if you do
if you're done get ready because today
we're counting down the top 10 most
hated characters in esports
starting off our list with a bang is
raise that sounds fine
they also saw
them perfect
watch them
dude this is the dumbest [ __ ] ever only
valon is supposed to be a tactical
shooter with precise gun play but
whoever designed reyes didn't get the
memo all of rey's abilities deal damage
or kill you by literally blowing you up
and since beta she's been hated for
basically making shooting seem worthless
we're playing a game that's supposed to
be kind of overwatchy kind of
counter-striking this guy is flying
through the air like i'm playing playing
quake bro you know what i'm saying and
he's shooting a rocket that doesn't kill
you in three hits it kills you in one
hit so he's got a halo rocket while he's
flying through the air like a quake
player you understand that i mean her
ult is literally a bazooka that one
shots you and all she needs to do is
sort of not really point it in your
general direction they won their very
first round on attack in the previous
round they're looking for two in a row
goodness gracious and caboose blows them
sky high while reyes has been dialed
back since the beta getting blown up by
a grenade or a rocket is still [ __ ]
pushing pushing
push that push through two tracks
[Music]
that's the most [ __ ] character out
there dude
sliding into our number nine spot is
satan i i mean mei from overwatch seeing
a may on the other team should send a
chill down your spine it means you're
about to spend the next 20 minutes
basically standing in place while she
slows you walls you off and freezes you
before putting an icicle in your head
and if getting killed in the slowest way
possible isn't frustrating enough the
rest of her kit lets her stall time and
objectives oh and she's nearly
impossible to kill mae is really good
here because look at this pathway that
you have to go through
or you can do that or you can do that
also
for free
eventually you guys gonna have to go
ahead and fight though
all right they should just get a dragon
and burn that wall down i'll get it
yeah wow clearly
clearly
like this this is just unreal this stall
tactic here from dallas jewels that's
the most ridiculous thing ever zach is
really good oh there we go zach's really
good at finding broken things and uh
exploiting them in the game if you've
seen some of his interviews he's like
well i play doomfist because he's broken
i play software because he's broken uh
and now he finds a way to stall the cart
without even fighting and to make things
worse her icicles have no range drop off
meaning she can spam that [ __ ] and
literally headshot you from across the
map great way for them to come up here
with a minute plus on the time bank if
the graph could be good if it could be
placed well
oh daunting that's huge kicked off the
rank looks from debate
at number eight we have bayonetta the
character that killed smash 4.
lost control of that segment he was up
2-0 and captain zach with the back door
3-0 to send us in the grand final set
number two we ain't done yet baby hold
that get gat and get to
[Applause]
i really understand why this is the last
evo
while people were hyped when bayonetta
was released in 2016 that excitement
quickly turned into hatred dude the
range on that is actually disgusting
dude i
hate this character bail was absolutely
broken even after getting nerfed she had
easy zero to death combos from basically
anywhere on screen and her witch town
ability punished you for even trying to
approach
but one flip up from jj over extension
and uh backers gonna do it oh no no this
probably isn't the stock but it's going
to be a ton of oh my
wow
she dominated almost every tournament to
the point where people considered
banning her and even after smash 4 was
replaced by ultimate the community still
carries hatred for that witch
fittingly coming in at number seven it's
tekken 7's version of akuma what's it
gonna do here black one oh it doesn't
get this toe spin and the side step
oh it doesn't get close with oh my god
that's going to be it no no oh my gosh
no way not like this
is going what's going on
please super cooper please when akuma
crossed over to the tekken universe in
2016 he fundamentally changed how tekken
was played akuma brought street fighter
mechanics to tekken including super
meter fa dc's fireballs and his unique
2d jump put it all together it just felt
unfair it's party time and chickering's
invited
oh here it is oh here we go
why did you say that mark i want to see
pardon oh my god look at the hell and
then the demon is the demon let's go i
can't believe what we're seeing look at
the life bar oh my goodness
he probably had a sliver right he might
have a sliver
oh my god oh my god let's go oh
the comeback most of tekken's cast just
couldn't keep up with akuma's insane
damage in 2d mechanics so before round
after round of nerfs akuma felt like an
out of control cheese pick tekken
purists also blame him for opening the
door for other cheesy 2d characters like
geese crossing over into tekken even
with the side we'll still be able to get
50 60 percent low power oh perry right
now
break it
hey screw still available
running elbow
yes
couldn't get the third one but damn we
got twitter video comments there it is
holy [ __ ]
he got super flower petals that's all
you got super stomp
oh my god you're dead two bars
stand up no just gonna kick him while
he's down goddamn
attaching herself to our number six slot
is you me from league of legends
dude this champion's
broken
oh she died of the poison this champion
is broken yumi is an enchanter support
except that she can attach herself to
another champion becoming their
untargetable pocket healer and turning
her host into an unkillable raid boss
vlogger just needs to be able to
actually defend the potential dive but
they're going to be isolated exhausted
he's getting burned down hot summer can
you turn this one back spent stepping
forward grabbing that first blood vulcan
still in the area but the umi can't you
finish the job oh
my god
oh that is the most embarrassing way to
die in league of legends and it just
happened i hate that cat enchanters are
usually super squishy but because yumi
is immune while attached she bypasses
this weakness completely her host
champion even moves for her when she's
attached yumi is the only champion you
can play the game with while watching
netflix and still win
i'm doing it
his way into the number five spot is
breach from valorant off your feet
let's try dude attackers
are so
stupid everyone's talking about race and
her grenades and her rockets and this
guy's like boom stun boom stun
with two flashes a stun and an ultimate
that knocks you back and concusses you
breech's kit is all about cc and because
all of his abilities go through walls
breech is able to throw all of that cc
at you without even seeing you making
him absolutely infuriating to play
against even playing with a breach is
annoying everyone's been stunned by an
ally breach at least once
climbing their way up into our number
four spot are the ice climbers and their
infamous wobble that's a very very very
expensive roll yeah yeah that
look look at him page with his life
all right now i'm checking twitter tweet
at
him wow my man is on social media right
now he's like i can't believe this guy
the ice climbers have an infinite combo
in melee and top players know that
getting one grab will pretty much always
lead to a guaranteed ko and guaranteed
salt oh he had to fade back he had
nowhere else to go oh and that is gonna
do it
that is gonna be an intended club
taking a sip of water he's not even
holding the controller
all right nintendo getting his sweet
revenge see a one-touch kill wouldn't be
that big a deal if it didn't take so
long to pull off the problem with
wobbling is that you're sitting there
for minutes while your opponent slowly
chips you to death isis and wobbling are
so hated that this one move has divided
the smash community leading some
tournaments to go as far as banning the
tech first of all i want to say yes i do
believe wobbling is
incredibly boring you get rewarded way
too much
for way too little work especially at
low level
uh low and mid level but even at pretty
high level i would say you get too
rewarded
with ics basically playing against ics
is like playing against a horror movie
monster one mistake means death and just
like a horror movie you're stuck
watching it for two hours
in our bronze medal spot we have the
tiny tear of the top lane teemo from
league can i double kill it or send a
okay you know what on that note that's
fine sure
oh my there's a freaking team on the
game gotta hate teemo
oh he's in the bush still oh i missed i
hate teemo jesus lord
i hate him he might be one of league's
unofficial mascots but don't be fooled
this cuddly yordle is one of the game's
biggest menaces
he's one shot again no no no no no no i
want you to hit it oh oh this guy's
rooted
i rooted him
it's good good keep chasing keep chasing
with a point and click blind and basic
attacks that poison you timo bullies the
hell out of other top laners forcing
them to take tons of damage whenever
they're farming
no
please i'm a virgin
i hate timo so much but what makes teemo
so hated are those damn mushrooms
somehow every enemy teemo can cover the
map with dozens of invisible explosive
mushrooms that'll chunk your hp
[Applause]
laughs
hacking her way into our runner-up spot
is sombra from overwatch
stops you from using abilities in an
ability-based shooter playing against a
somber means saying goodbye to your
blinks shields and well
everything and lip is eyeing up this
fire
if there are anything like rocks he's
going for it he's going for an emp
they're gonna be dropping right off the
edge of the map
sombra can stealth indefinitely so you
never know if she's about to unstealth
and hack you or if she's stealthing into
your back line to assassinate your
squishies
okay
there's a reason the only people who
like sombra are sombermans
because she can see me through walls
because of my low hp
oh come on what a piece of [ __ ] man that
character
[Music]
at our number one spot we have techies
from dota 2. what just happened where's
gem please
we need a gem guys someone drop this
sorry for gem or something i don't know
we lost okay gg
oh my god can we please have a gem like
what the [ __ ] is wrong with this game
where's our gems techies is essentially
teemo dialed up to 100. he only lives to
plant mines that insta-kill you in game
and jump scare you in real life
like most mobos dota 2 is all about
teamwork unfortunately techies was
designed for a player to ignore their
team and just [ __ ] off on their own for
40 minutes win or lose i've gotten
banned before playing techies
i got a four day ban or something from
dota because i got reported for picking
techies everyone reported me every
single game i picked techies every game
techies forces opponents to play
minesweeper instead of actually playing
dota playing against them induces a
crippling psychological fear that
nowhere on the map is safe
[Laughter]
i hate tickies man even the guy who use
techies to win ti hates this stupid hero
when that hero's in the game uh
only he's having fun that's how i feel
about it and did you have fun playing of
course he's super fun okay so you want
to ban him for everybody else but you
were happy to use him in game two i mean
i'd be done if you just removed from the
game but like if he's in the game we're
gonna use it right
and that's our list if you hate a
character but they aren't on this list
or you main a character that happens to
be on this list let us know down the
comment section below take care and
we'll see you in the next one
we got this
sometimes we just win the game